what a été tu as vécu ton qu'ovide tu as
eu beaucoup de symptômes tu n'as pas
trop souffert mais toi surtout c'est tu
viens avec ta maman et ça a été aussi un
cauchemar parce que je vais vous avoir
soit parce que ces deux cas complètement
différents mais deux cas qui peuvent
être similaires avec d'autres personnes
qui nous regarde moi c'était j'ai fait
les choses en grand le premier jour du
premier confinement j'ai tout c'est le
premier jour j'ai eu 39 5 le deuxième
donc j'ai fait venir sos médecins donc
il faut se replacer dans le contexte on
ne savait rien on n'avait pas le moindre
masquer le moindre test j'ai fait venir
sos médecins mais comme une pestiférée
il m'a jetée cardiaque quasiment
l'ordonance est la seule chose qui m'a
dit m'a dit c'est peut-être la grippe
donc on va vous soigner pour la grippe
mais si c'est le cas vis de toute façon
on n'a rien donc je vous rassure et ça
il faut le maximum je alors je ne leur
jette pas du tout là j'aurais juste dans
le contact qui ne savaient rien donc ne
jouez pas faire il avait aucun donc
c'est vraiment là il a fait ce qu'il a
pu
simplement il m'a dit cette phrase et je
elle a tourné en boucle pendant quinze
jours ça m'a traumatisée si vous
n'arrivez même pas finir une phrase
tellement vous êtes essoufflé appeler le
et c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire pour
vous il m'a dit vous n'êtes pas passé
comme ça donc ça c'est la nuit moi j'ai
essayé de parler doucement pour pas
réveillé ma mère pour voir si je pouvais
finir une phrase j'ai vu voilà en fait
j'ai eu beaucoup de fièvre une fatigue
énorme tous les symptômes mais je
m'estime privilégié par rapport à ceux
qui vont évidemment qui sont
hospitalisés à sion que c'est plus sain
de quoi laisser les angoisses d'abord
pour moi parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment à
quel âge et je vis dans 1 40 mètre carré
avec ma mère qui à 89 ans et quand je
dis ça au médecin la seule chose qui m'a
dit encore une fois on n'a pas de masque
cegedim et je vais je vais la tuer enfin
je vais si je lui passe le coc vite
qu'est ce que je fais il m'a dit on n'a
pas de membres issus est tous là
peut-être une façon asymptomatique parce
que les personnes âgées peuvent parce
qu'autrement c'est un miracle on est
dans 1 40 mètre carré j'ai fait ce que
j'ai pu mais là pour voler l'alzheimer
et donc elle n'a jamais compris ce que
c'était que ce virus donc parfois c'est
hyper dur elle pleurait parce que je ne
l'embrassé pas elle croyait que j'étais
fâchée elle se demandait ce que j'avais
fait qu'est ce que c'est horrible ça
c'était ça déjà c'était cette
incompréhension cette angoisse de lui
les transmettre quand je l'entendais
tous et la nuit je me disais c'est bien
je lui donnais et je me savais que je me
sentirai responsable si elle l'avait
donc j'ai vraiment vécu la double peine
et j'ai vécu quinze jours horribles
maman est atteinte de la maladie
d'alzheimer donc tu dois m'occuper
d'elle c'est vrai que là on ne pouvons
pas l'approcher et on essayant d'éviter
de la contaminer forcément ça t'a mis
dans des situations le problème c'est ça
c'est que je ne pouvais même pas muselée
par exemple on peut me dire mais
pourquoi t'as pas été à l'hôtel pour la
protéger elle ne peut pas vivre seul et
qu'ils pouvaient venir s'occuper d'elle
c'était risqué pour elle et pour on
n'est que cette maladie si tu aurais
parce qu'on a peur de l'autre en fait
s'il n'ya pas pire qu'en fait parce que
quand quelqu'un est malade on va
évidemment vers lui on va l'aider on
prend dans ses bras
là on est obligé d'avoir peur de l'autre
d'avoir d'avoir peur pour l'autre face
c'est une maladie qui est très
pernicieuse pour ça et voilà donc moi je
oui j'ai vraiment vécu la double peine
physiquement ça a été très dur parce que
c'est une fatigue qu'on ne peut pas
imaginer quand on a pas mais moralement
ça a été vraiment mais une angoisse de
tous les instants vous rendez compte
c'était le moment où jérôme salomon
donner le nombre de morts chaque soir et
et vous savez automne alors que
peut-être elle est consciente qu'il ya
cette crise ou pas dû à la non pas du
tout l or elle ne sais pas pourquoi les
gens mettent le masque elle me dit
qu'est ce que c'est que cette mode
idiote c'est moche pourquoi tout le
monde met un masque elle est dans son
monde bon c'est plutôt tant mieux tant
mieux pour elle elle moi je me disais
c'est pas demander pourquoi vous restiez
à distance d'elles elles croyaient que
j'étais fâché j'essayais de lui dire
mais le problème c'est qu'on lui si on
explique jean qui ont alzheimer et cinq
minutes après ils ont oublié donc ça a
été vraiment ça c'était triste parce
qu'elle ne comprenait pas mal j'ai pensé
que je n'ai pas aimé pendant quinze
jours quoi c'était je pense que dans sa
tête c'était ça donc voilà il ya tout ça
qui fait que je pense que je ne suis pas
la seule dans ce cas là et en ehpad
doivent aider vécu des moments vous êtes
dit je vais craquer je vais déjà moi je
en fait on va pas se mentir j'ai
jusqu'au jeu quand même pas mal de cases
jeu pour l'imc scientifiquement je suis
obèses j'ai une maladie cardiaque donc
j'ai une comorbidité donc moi j'étais
quand même à haut risque quoi en plus
donc j'ai vraiment déjà eu peur pour moi
j'ai pas en devenir j'avais peur je ne
dormais pas la nuit j'ai perdu 8 kilos
ça c'est plutôt bien sauf que je les ai
repris mais parce que j'avais déjà une
angoisse personnelle et puis on l'a
encore une fois j'avais vraiment la
double peine dès qu'elle toussait
s'était essayée vous pouvez vous sentir
après responsable d'avoir quand dans une
épidémie c'est ça quand vous
réunissez m'efforce parce que c'est une
stèle fatigue d'abord pour m'occuper un
petit peu des la distance mais il
fallait que je fasse des certaines
choses et puis je nettoyais ce que je
pouvais mais c'était dérisoire parce
qu'on est dans un 42 m² quoi je vais
essayer de faire pleurer mais c'est la
verrez c'est la réalité c'était très dur
comment voyager c'est quand vous voyez
ceux qui ne respectent pas le
confinement qui font participent à des
fêtes bal et voilà les fêtes par exemple
les fêtes clandestines les jeunes c'est
il danse sur un volcan on est il faut
qu'on soit une équipe de 68 millions de
personnes contre 9 soit tous dans la
même direction
personne n'a envie de vivre ça alors
défaite ils en auront d'autres à 20 ans
voit bien sûr que c'est pas rigolo mais
vous en aurez d'autres défaites tandis
que là il va y avoir des tas de gens
âgés qui vont être seul pour noël ce
sera peut-être leur dernier noël donc
sacrifions un tout petit peu et fait on
peut quand même vivre sans danser sans
sens rassemblés pendant quelques temps
je suis désolé c'est bien sûr c'est un
sacrifice mais franchement je pense que
le jeu en vaut la chandelle quoi il faut
qu'on s'en débarrasse
et il faut qu'on pense à moi je en ce
moment ma mère était à l'hôpital au
service gériatrie aiguë je peux vous
dire que voilà déjà être âgés c'est pas
facile mais si en plus on prend pas soin
d'eux en ce moment je pense que tout le
monde a une grand mère quelqu'un d'âgé
dans sa famille